in the last video you saw the equations
for back propagation in this video let's
go over some intuition using the
computation crop for how those equations
would arrive this video is completely
optional so feel free to watch it or not
you should be able to do the whole world
either way so recall that when we talked
about logistic regression we had this
forward pass where we compute Z then a
and then a loss and then to take
derivatives we had this sum backward
pass where we can first compute da
and then go on to compute GZ and we go
on to compute DW and DP so the
definition for the loss was L of a comma
y equals negative Y log a minus 1 minus
y Times log 1 minus a so if you're
familiar with calculus and you take the
derivative of this with respect to a
that would give you the formula for da
so da is equal to that and if you
actually figure out the calculus you can
show that this is y over a negative PI
over 8 plus 1 minus y over 1 minus a
let's just kind of divide that from
calculus by taking derivatives of this
it turns out when you take another step
backwards to compute GZ we then worked
out that D Z is equal to a minus y I
didn't explain why previously but it
turns out that from the chain rule of
calculus DZ is equal to DA times G prime
of Z where here G of Z equals sigmoid of
Z is our activation function for this
output unit in logistic regression
alright so just remember this is still
logistic regression we'll have X 1 X 2 X
V and then just one sigmoid unit and
then that gives us some al gives us Y
hat so here the activation function was
a sigmoid function and as an aside
only for those of you familiar with the
chain rule of calculus the reason for
this is because a is equal to Sigma of Z
and so partial L respect to Z is equal
to partial L respect to a times da DZ
but since a is equal to Sigma of Z this
is equal to D DZ G of Z right which is
equal to G prime of Z so that's why this
expression which is DZ and our code is
equal to this expression which is da and
our code times G prime of Z and so this
is just that so that last derivation
what makes ends over here from you're
familiar with calculus since the speed
is a chamber from calculus but if not
don't worry about it
I'll try to explain the intuition
wherever this needed and then finally
having computed easy for you to
depression we would compute DW which it
turns out with DZ times X and DB which
is just easily when you have a single
training example
so that was logistic regression so what
we're going to do when computing back
propagation for a neural network is a
calculation a lot like this but only
we'll do it twice because now we have
not extinct an output unit but X going
to a hidden layer and then going to an
output unit and so instead of them
instead of this computation being select
one step as we have here what happened
you know two steps here right in this
kind of a neural network with two layers
so in this two layer neural network that
is one input layer hidden layer and an
output layer remember the steps of a
computation first you compute z1 using
this equation and then compute a 1 and
then you compute Z 2 and then open z2
also depends on the parameters W 2 and V
and then based on G to compute a to and
finally that gives you the loss so what
back propagation does is it will go
backward to compute da to and then DZ to
let them go back to compute D w2 and DB
to go backwards compute da 1 DZ 1 and so
on
and we don't need to take derivatives
respect to the input X since the input X
for supervised learning I think so we're
not trying to optimize X so we won't
bother to take derivatives at least for
supervised learning or respect to X and
so I'm going to skip explicitly
computing da 2 if you want you can
actually compute da 2 and then use that
to compute GZ 2 but in practice you can
collapse both of these steps into one to
one step see ends up DZ 2 is equal to a
2 minus y same as before and you have
also I'm going to write DW 2 and DP 2
down here below you have that DW 2 is
equal to GZ 2 times a 1 transpose and DB
2 equals D Z 2 so this step is quite
similar to for logistic regression where
we had that DW was equal to DZ times X
accepted now a 1 plays the role of X and
does it makes a transpose there because
the relationship between the capital
matrix W and our individual parameters W
was there's a transpose there right
because W is equal to UM a row vector in
the case of logistic regression with a
single output V W 2 is like that where
it W here was a column vector so that's
why there's an extra transpose for a one
where as we did in 2 for X here for
logistic regression so
this completes half of backpropagation
and then again you can compute da one if
you wish although in practice the
computation for da 1 and DZ 1
I usually collapse into one step and so
what you actually implement is that DZ 1
is equal to W 2 transpose times easy to
and then times an element-wise product
of G 1 prime of Z 1 and just to do a
check on the dimensions right if you
have a mirror network that looks like
this all right outputs y so if you have
n 0 and x equals n 0 input features and
1 hidden units and n 2 so far and n 2 in
our case just one output unit then the
matrix W 2 is n 2 by N 1 dimensional Z 2
and therefore DZ 2 are going to be n 2
by 1 dimensional this is really going to
be a 1 by 1 1 where 2 in binary
classification and Z 1 and therefore
also GZ 1 are going to be n 1 by 1
dimensional right note that for any
variable foo foo and V foo always have
the same dimension so that's why W and
DW you know always have the same
dimension and similarly for B and D P
and C and D Z and so on so to make sure
that the dimensions of this all match up
we have that D Z 1 is equal to W 2
transpose times D Z 2 and then um this
is an element-wise
product times G 1 prime of Z 1 so
mashing the dimensions from above this
is going to be N 1 by 1 is equal to
double
to transpose V consoles of this so just
going to be and 1 by n two-dimensional
DV 2 is going to be n 2 by 1 dimensional
and then this this is the same dimension
as z1 so this is also n 1 by 1 dimension
also element wise product so the
dimensions do make sensor and n 1 by 1
dimensional vector can be obtained by
and 1 by n 2 dimensional matrix times n
2 by N 1 because the product of these
two things gives you and one by one
dimensional matrix and so this becomes
the element wise product of two and one
by one dimensional vectors and so the
dimensions do match up once if when
implementing backdrop on if you just
make sure that the dimensions of your
matrix is match up so if you think
through what are the dimensions of your
various matrices including W 1 W 2 Z 1 Z
2 a 1 a 2 and so on and just make sure
that the dimensions of these matrix
operations may match up sometimes that
will already eliminate quite a lot of
bugs in that row all right so this gives
us D Z 1 and then finally just to wrap
up DW 1 and DB 1 we should break them
here I guess but since I'm running out
of space I'll write them on the right of
the slide DW 1 and DB 1 are given by the
following formulas this is going to
equal to GZ 1 times X transpose and this
is going to be equal to DZ and you might
notice a similarity between these
equations and these equations which is
really no coincidence because X plays
the role of a zero so X transpose is a 0
transpose so those equations are
actually are very similar all right so
that gives a sense for how back
propagation is derived and we have six
key equations here for um D Z 2 DW 2 DB
2 DZ 1 DW 1 + DP 1 so let me just take
these six equations and copy them over
to the next slide
here they are and so far with divided
backpropagation for if your training on
a single training example at a time but
it should come as no surprise that
rather than working on a single example
at a time we would like to vectorize
across different training examples so
you remember that forward propagation
where we're operating on one example at
a time we have equations like this um as
well as say a1 equals G 1 of Z 1 and in
order to vectorize we took say the Z's
and stack them up in columns like this V
1 M and call this capital Z and then we
found that you know by setting things up
in columns and defining the capital
uppercase version of these we then just
had Z 1 equals W 1 X plus B and a 1
equals G 1 of Z 1 right and we define
the notation very carefully in this code
to make sure that some stacking examples
in two different columns of the matrix
makes all this work out so it turns out
that if you go through the math
carefully the same trick also works for
back propagation so the vectorize
equations are as follows first if you
take these disease for different
training examples and stack them at the
different columns of the matrix and same
for this and same for this then this is
the vectorized implementation and then
here's the definition for or shears how
you can compute d w2
on there is this extra 1 over m because
you know the cost function J is d'azyr
one over m of sum from I equals 1
through m of the losses and so when
computing derivatives we have that extra
1 over m term just as we did when we
were computing the weight updates for
logistic regression and then that's the
update you get for db2 again some of the
disease and then with a 1 over N and
then d z1 is computed as follows once
again this is an element-wise product
only whereas previously this was we saw
on the previous slide that this was an N
1 by 1 dimensional vector now this is a
n 1 by M dimensional matrix and both of
these are also + 1 by M dimensional and
so that's why that activist is a
element-wise product and then finally
the remaining two updates um perhaps
shouldn't look too surprising so I hope
that gives you some intuition for how
the back propagation algorithm is
derived in all of machine learning
I think the derivation of the back
propagation algorithm is actually one of
the most complicated pieces of math I've
seen and it requires knowing both linear
algebra as well as the derivative
matrices to really derive it from
scratch from first principles if you are
an expert in matrix calculus using this
process you might go to derive the
algorithm yourself but I think that
there actually plenty of deep learning
practitioners that have seen the
derivation at about the level you've
seen in this video and are already able
to have all the very intuitions and
people implement this algorithm very
effectively so the RNA excluding
calculus do see if you can divide the
whole thing from scratch it is one of
the very hardest pieces of math or the
very hardest derivations that I've seen
in all of machine learning but either
way if implemented you know this will
work and I think you have enough into
to tune and get it to work so that
there's just one last detail when I
share view before you implement your
neural network which is how to
initialize the weights of the neural
network and it turns out that
initializing your parameter is not to 0
but randomly turns out to be very
important for training your network in
the next video you see why